hallo YouTube just love us in our
friends this is grunge in here welcome
to the fourth episode of dirty chats
tricks against sicilian in this lecture
I'm going to show you some of the
wonderful tricks against Sicilian
x-rated dragony which arises after the
Mordor efore c5 Knight to f3 and black
plays over here Knight to c6 mainline
goes as follows
so place the move d4 C captors d4 Knight
captures d4 and here a black respond
with the move g6 so Ida has to play the
move Bishop to g7 Knight to f6 Castle on
the Kings side and then quickly look out
for the move defy at the right time now
against this opening I have already
created a video so if you haven't seen
that I strongly recommend that you can
go and watch that video
I have also highlighted the link in the
annotations and still if you can't find
it just search in YouTube Sicilian
exited dragon by GJ chess and you are
able to see my video however this is a
new video so that's why I'm going to
show you some of the new tricks in this
finish now especially for this opening
I'm not going to recommend Knight to f3
instead of that I am going to propose at
this Junction you should play the move
Knight to c3 the usual who goes as
Knight to c6 afterwards
White has this second good move that is
Bishop to b5 so idea is that Bishop
wants to capture the night and giving
black a double bond if your opponent
allow you to do this then I strongly
recommend that you learn the theory of
Cecil and Rosalie Moe or Cecil and grant
three attack where this concepts are
explained very beautifully the main move
here is night to d4 however one may can
ask what happens after Queen to c7 we're
here like we'll continue with the move
Knight to f3 and after the usual
response that is a 6 yes definitely
lack is going to grab the bishop pair
but in return White has tremendous
leading development so you can already
see why has done of his two minor pieces
the queen is a track and in the next
move but is able to castle on the
kingside so all in all this is a
wonderful compensation for the white so
that's why it's very essential for black
that at this point black has to play the
move Knight to d4 which also attack the
bishop here white will continue with the
move Bishop to c4 and now there are two
moves has been tried the main move of
the exited dragon is to play the Moon g6
afterwards white will continue with the
move either night we have three or let's
say in this game white plays the move
Knight to e2 here usually black continue
with the move Bishop to g7 afterwards
why it has this amazing move that is
Knight captures d4 and at first sight it
looks completely stupid because black
can easily capture this night with the C
pawn which not only equalized black
instantly but that D pawn is a monster
in white cam and also black is achieved
the Trump of the Sicilian that is
getting the C file open so the question
is why white is doing all this well if I
told you that C captures D for create
amazing high-profile trick just in the
fourth move the game then you will be
amazed it doesn't look like black has
any weaknesses in his camp and still
white obtained the advantage let's see
how so the first move white has to play
is Quint we have three so you can
already see black doesn't have any time
to capture the night because there is a
mate on f7 and accordingly black has few
responses I have reached this position
ten times in my game and most of my
opponent has choose either the move
Knight to f6 or c6 where Bo
leads to the wonderful tricks now if
back wants to play the accurate move
then he has to play the Moon Knight to
f6 which hardly be considered by your
opponent the simple reason is let's say
if even black played the move Knight to
f6
then white will continue with the move
d3 so now what is threatening to play
the move Bishop captures at 6 so black
has to castle on the Kings side
afterwards what will continue with the
Moon Knight to e2 and the usual line
goes with the move d6 trying to get in
the move Bishop to g4 which is white
prevent with the s3 and now you can see
the problem with that night that night
is completely out of the game and it
will take a while for black to reroute
that night and coming back in the cave
so that's the main reason why not many
of your opponent is going to play the
moon night at 6 the most frequent
response is Knight to f6 but this is
also a big mistake because here comes
the first week on the table y is going
to play the move Knight to d5 and
straight away white will be up on up now
there are two ways black and defend this
d4 pawn but all miserably fails so if
black continue with the movie Phi then
this is already a disaster because you
can already see that a Juicy's d6 square
is asking to be hit and we are
definitely going to put our knight on
the D 6 square with the check and after
King moves for example King to have
faith then Knight to f7 and fight his
complete heavy knee so IVA is prohibited
same can be said for the move Queen to
b6 because now black has a huge problem
after this moon that is e Phi BAM please
note if the knight moves then there is a
nasty happening on the AB 7 square and I
have reached this position against a
player who is 2000 plus
and after a long thinking he responded
here with the move Knight to H fire so
his idea is to protect the bishop when I
take on AB 7 however I found a stronger
rule that is G fo haha so that night is
attack the epsilon is attack and black
is in a miserable position he come out
from all this difficulty with a very
good move that is Quinn to c6 but after
a few calculation I go with this line
which gives a clear advantage to
dividing so here I continue with the
move Bishop captures f7 check
he played King to D H and now I played
the move Knight captures d4 which more
or less forced the issue because now
black has to capture the Queen I
recapture with my knight and now my
opponent played the counter-attacking
move that is rook to f8 no problem I
defended my bishop with the move Knight
to g5 he played the move at six which is
a weaker move because now after a few
exchanges that is G captures H by H
captures G Phi H captures g6 and Bishop
captures ePHI the dust is clear and
white has come out two points ahead from
this whole transaction not to mention
there is a loose key in Gandhi eight and
whites G pond is just two steps away
from the Queenie so seeing all this it's
very obvious that the best move here is
to play the move a six which at first
sight looks too good but again there is
a problem and the problem is when y
plays the move Knight to B Phi then the
D six square is hanging now there are
few ways that can try to defend the D
six square but they all miserably fails
the only good reply is P six but let's
see what happens
if black plays other replies if the
Queen b6 then the simplest of all is
Queen to f4
and then you can already see there is no
stopping on c7 and d6 if the move Bishop
to e5 then I can continue with the move
c3 and after D capture C 3 and d 4 in
the view of stopping Knight to d6 check
bishop has to go all the way back to the
BH but after this I can capture the c3
pawn and not only White is ahead in
development but you can already see that
dark square around the black King side
becomes severely week and that Bishop
won't be it is severely misplaced so
this is almost a great positional
advantage if black plays the move defy
which at first say it looks too good but
the problem over here is what can
continue with the move he captures defy
and if black plays the move a 6 then
after D captures c6 threatening a
checkmate on f7 so black has to capture
with the pawn and now white will
retrieve his knight back to the e3 so
after all this white emerge with a clear
point up but also black king is somewhat
open and the center is not stable so
this position is also wonderful for
white so considering all this the d6
move looks best as for the situation and
after this move it doesn't look like
White has any sort of tricks left well
here comes amazing trick before we going
to seed it I like to thank I am valeera
Liu because I have learned this trick
from one of his game now I want you to
pause over here and find a wonderful
move which confirms a great advantage to
white ok I hope you find this mu that is
Queen to a3 so double attack on d6
there are two ways black and defend but
the first one that is Bishop to e5 looks
pathetic because it's only allow white
to enhance its development wire the MU
castle at same time creating a threat of
f4 so this cannot be good so the only
move looks like is Bishop to f8
afterwards white can simply capture the
d4 pawn and the trick is finish right
there then you may be asked what white
have achieved well if you carefully look
at the position after the whites Knight
captures V four-plex
every single piece are sitting at its
original position while still he is upon
down isn't that amazing
and on top of everything White has three
pcs already in the game so this is one
of the very high profile trap and I'll
give you guarantee many higher rated
players are going to fall for it now
before we go and look at the second
trick there's one question need to be
answered that what happens if black
played the move defy because it looks
like there's a discover attack on the
Queen and black can regain the pawn once
again I like you to pause the video and
to find a sequence where white can
retain his extra pawn okay so the first
obvious move is to giving a check and
after the move Bishop to d7 I should
capture this Bishop and after Queen
captures White has this very strong move
that is Queen to g3 and this is more or
less confirms upon advantage obviously
black cannot capture this pawn at this
Junction because if be kept is e4 then
after Queen to e5 Black has the only mu
laugh
is f6 afterwards what is going to be
porn up not only by capturing the e4
pawn but there's a pressure on a six
point as well so that is not possible
and if black try to be tricky and
playing the move Bishop to g7 then after
the movie Phi Queen to c7 and f4
Queen to b6 and c3 finally White has
consolidate his position and remain a
point up so please remember this Queen
to g3 move if you open and play the move
defy now the second move black and try
over here is to play the move a six so
going back into the rims of time on O or
the combination well here white will
continue with the move Knight to e2 and
the whole idea is to play the move
Knight to e7 and then quickly go for the
defy well it looks so good but the
problem is why it is in fact allowing
this move d5 and go for the castle at
first sight the blacks position looks
tremendous
after the Moody file because after
ecaptions' be fine he kept his defy its
attacked the bishop and black has
already cover up the center which limits
the activity of the white pieces so far
every move black has played is quite
good but there is a problem that right
now black king is stuck in the center so
that gives privilege to the y to
sacrifice a material and here comes the
another boom Knight captures d5 so let's
see what happens if black accept this
piece sacrifice in fact black has true
otherwise black will be upon down for
nothing
so Knight captures defy now the
following lines are very forceful one so
first white will capture this night and
after C
captures v4 white will play this move
that is Queen to h5 so attacking two
spots the main spot is the d5 square and
if the knight rules then there is a
attack on the upsell black has the only
decent move that is Bishop to e6 of
course black can play over here Knight
to e7
but then black will have a low honking
dance and those positions are quite good
for the white so Bishop to e6 protecting
the d5 and now white will play the move
rook to e1 so once again creating a pin
and now that Knight is definitely
hanging so far I reached this position
two times in the first game my opponent
responded over here with the move Knight
to f4 which at first I looked so good
because it's attacking the Queen and the
same time protecting the bishop but what
has us very strong over here and that is
yup Bishop to b5 check the only movers
came to e7 afterwards the very simple
move Queen to g4 not only regaining a
piece but black King will remain in the
center for a long long time so that
cannot be good the second move drive is
Bishop to e7 which at first sight looks
so good but it has a problem and that is
boom fruit captures e6 and that pawn is
spin so black cannot do about that rook
here my opponent continued with the MU
g6 and thought that it will win my rook
in the next move but after Queen to e5
attacking the black rogue castle on the
King side
I simply capture the knight on the D
file in the game is finished right there
the father moves played like this so my
opponent captured my rook I capture the
e6 pawn with my bishop and this is a
force check which black has to block
with the rook and now I
the new d3 so after the whole fireworks
you can easily see when white is going
to capture this roof the material will
be balanced as far as the PCs are
concerned but in terms of pawns whities
two points ahead in the game and black
has weak pawn on the d4 so those are
some of the wonderful and high-profile
tricks in exited dragon and do not
forget to watch my previous video which
also contains lots of tricks and traps
against exit red dragon
well thank you for watching this video
feel free to like subscribe and comment
on my video and I'll meet you in my next
episode bye